You are listening to radio lab radio lab
from
W. N. Y. S. T. E. N. N. P.
R. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. Hi,
I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab,
the podcast. Yes. Nick,
you were a little off our game right
now because we are not in our normal
studio. We're actually in
Detroit right now. We're on tour.
We're in the first leg of our
tour. It's super fun going well,
but we do have an interesting
podcast for you who you do indeed,
but it might be more efficient
if we go back to New York. We're,
Soren wheeler is standing by because he
and I had a conversation with someone.
We can just, yes. Yeah. Do you want to,
do you want to carry it forward? Sure.
Do it.
So today we have a story of an obsession
that deep swallowed reporter Dan Ingber
and disappeared pretty much whole of
all the things to catch your attention.
How did this happen to pop into your head?
It happened to pop into my head because
I was talking to a friend of mine who's
an elementary school teacher and
we were discussing quicksand as,
as one does. Oh Gosh, it's elementary
school teacher and I, and she just said,
you know, the kids in my class
just don't even, they don't,
they've never heard of quicksand. Like
second graders, third grade. Like what?
Nine year old, 10 year old. Fourth
grade is prime time for quicksand.
Right when I was nine, quicksand
was a major part of my life. Yeah.
We live, you know, poor water in the
corner of the sandbox and say, oh,
it's quicksand, but you're your teacher
friends. Students didn't, right.
But so I went to, to
her, I visited her class.
I might discover that she was wrong.
Almost all of them had heard of quicksand,
but she was right in so far as quicksand
was not important to them. In fact,
they thought it wasn't scary
at all. And I was like, well,
what are you afraid of?
And they said, you know,
zombies, the alien in Pacific Rim Ghost,
when I was actually lost a writing
being attacked by a dinosaur,
that would be totally more scary.
So we actually went and talked to some
third graders and while some of them
said,
well, I guess it's Sorta scary, but
most of them weren't scared of it at all.
I don't think so. I usually
don't think about it.
They thought it was something that
maybe their parents had been afraid of.
They told me that when he was little,
his friends always said like, look out.
That could be quicksand.
Friends ever say that to you? Yeah,
they would say people used to be scared
of that, but it's not scary anymore.
So that got me to thinking what happened?
Why is quicksand not scary the way it
used to be? And with that simple question,
Dan got sucked into a world
he never even knew existed.
So the next step was going to the Internet
and within a minute I discovered the
quicksand fetish. Community
it quick fetish. Yeah,
like fetish fetish. Like
sex fetish. Yes. Oh,
so then so in the quick, among
the quicksand fetishists,
there are so called sinkers.
These are people who seek out quicksand
in nature and want to jump in with
another person and kiss or are by
themselves with no clothes on or,
or is the sex part some of them
by themselves with no clothes on,
some smaller group with another person.
That's if they can convince
their partner to come with them.
But they always have a rope with
them, I hope. Oh yeah. Oh, if you go,
if you go onto the sinkers message boards,
there's a Google map which has sinking
spots all over the world and each one is
rated for, you know, thickness,
depth, privacy available,
parking nearby. I mean, it's a really,
it's been very thought through and,
and wonderfully collaborative community.
So there's sinkers in one hand
and then there are the watchers.
They just want to see people where
animals sinking into quicksand.
So they'll watch movies and just find
the quicksand sequence in the movie.
And here's where Dan sunk even d
because he discovered that one of these
watchers,
this guy crypto had in the course of his
fetishistic quicksand watching Colada
dis, you know, this list of,
of well over a thousand quicksand
scenes in film and television,
this part of the country.
There were scenes going all the way
back to the birth of filmmaking. I mean,
this is the greatest impetus for
scientific research to take off your shoe.
And if you have to like a
fetishistic interest in the data.
And Dan thought maybe this data can give
us a clue about how the way we think
about quicksand has changed.
So I went through and I pulled out every
feature film from the list and then
with information from the MPA,
I figured out how many movies
were being released every decade.
And then I sort of computed a,
like what percent of movies had quicksand?
And every decade going back to, uh,
the first quicksand movie they
have is from 19 Tino nine.
It's a silent film where a woman gets
rescued from quicksand by some hooded
monks. I'm unable to find this
movie, but I'd love to see it.
I don't know what it's
about. Um, but anyways,
I s I started looking at the number of
movies by decade and the beginning of the
century, it's like one
in a thousand movies.
By the 30s it's up to one in 500 and then
in the forties one and 200 and then in
the 1960s all of a sudden it just shoots
up like one in 35 like almost 3% of
Hollywood movies have quicksand.
The 1960s are just clearly
a moment for quicksand
and Dan says it wasn't
just the number of films,
the quicksand scenes that showed up
in the 60s were serious dramatic seas.
For example, Lawrence of Arabia
where Peter Ode tool is, you know,
pushing through the dust storm to try
to save his companions is being sucked
under.
That movie won seven Oscars and then
women in the dunes came out this like art,
see Japanese existentialist meditation.
And for about the next 10 years,
Dan says you had all these serious films
that featured quicksand and then it
fell off dramatically in the 1970s.
It's already fallen to something like
one out of 75 and then by the 1980s,
it's like one out of 130. And then
in the 90s, quicksand is mostly gone.
Huh.
And I think also in the 80s that
had migrated into help television,
I'm stuck in quicksand. Boy.
Yeah, you have a one bad day.
Larry and Belky and perfect strangers
are falling into quicken sand.
There's quick sand in my
little [inaudible] pony.
It's quicksand in Rainbow
Pride. I mean, it's Zany.
Quicksand basically dances.
Quicksand had become a joke. And so,
and that's the end, I think when,
when quicksands in, you know,
Saturday cartoons, I think,
I do think that adventure
gags probably have, um,
a lifespan. So just for a gut check,
Dan and I decided maybe we should run
this past somebody who knows the business.
I'm Carlton cuse and I'm a television
writer and producer and Carlton was
actually the showrunner
for the TV show lost.
And that's a show that by rights
should have tons of quicksand. I mean,
absolutely, they should be in
quicksand all the time. They're on,
they're stranded on a tropical
island. It's an adventure show.
But according to Carlton, whenever one
of the writers would say, you know, okay,
so Kate goes running down a path and
then all of a sudden she falls into a pit
of quicksand. The rest of
them would be like, um,
um, uh, I don't know if we
can really pull that off.
So what is that like? What is it?
It would make that not, I, you know,
I just think a lot of people would
sort of be rolling their eyes and not,
and not buying it.
That's, I know it sounds,
it sounds kind of crazy because you know
who you are making sort of a crazy show
with smoke monsters and polar bears and
time travel. And for someone to say,
no, no, no, but we don't believe
quicksand. I know. It's, um,
but ultimately you just
sort of trust your gut.
And just right now we're
quicksand is just not sort of,
I think the right metaphor for how
we're all feeling. But in the 60s,
it because someone speculated as to
the reason why the 60s. Oh, I've,
I've speculated, uh, at
great wave. I mean, it's,
it's a fascinating moment
because it's not just in movies.
I believe that this nation
should commit itself.
So we're planning the moon
mission in the early sixties,
a man on the moon and returning
him safely to the earth.
And this Cornell astronomer
named Thomas Gold has what if,
when the Apollo lander descends
to the surface of the Moon,
it just sinks into a lunar
quicksand. I remember this.
I remember Tom Gold saying that too. Yeah.
So right at this golden
moment of quicksand,
people are discussing real life
quicksand on the frontier of that.
Yeah. Now is the time.
And then 1963 Martin Luther
King now is the time.
Makes us,
I have a dream speech foundation from
the quip sense of racial and Tufts does.
He says,
now is the time to lift our nation from
the quicksands of racial injustice.
And then I came here to speak to you
about Vietnam. There was Vietnam.
I do not have to tell you that our people
are profoundly concerned about that
struggle, that we now think of
Vietnam as having been a quagmire.
That's the [inaudible]
rhetoric that's used now.
But the debate in the 60s between Daniel
Ellsberg and Arthur Schlesinger, uh,
they use quicksand and quagmire
interchangeably. They just,
the Ellsberg will switch
off and one essay,
we'll call it a quick
sand and then a quagmire.
But the first use of that idea was to
describe it as a quick sand. And then it,
it kind of migrates from being a quick
sand to a quagmire over the course of the
late sixties and early seventies.
And now, I mean, more evidence.
Now we call it a quagmire.
We forgot that Vietnam was a
quicksand before it was a quagmire.
So I'm all of these levels,
quicksand is just, you know,
as part of these key
moments of this 1960s. Wow.
So the question that
you know, that was just,
I was obsessed with for a long time was
why did America fall into quicksand in
the 1960s I mean,
did it come out of the movies and suddenly
everyone's talking about it or was
everyone talking about it?
And so maybe everybody saw Lawrence of
Arabia and they all went back to their
jobs, right?
Then we're on rocket ship jobs and
somewhere on wharfie where are your jobs?
And they all just carried Peter
O'Toole in their heads as possible.
I suppose that's possible. Who knows? I,
my sense is that it,
it's had to do with just sort of a
generalized anxiety about going someplace
radically new anxiety about, you know,
the Hubris of traveling to the moon,
anxiety about social upheaval,
anxiety about the foreign entanglement
of Vietnam and the state of geopolitics.
[inaudible]
well, why, why would that,
those anxieties manifest themselves
in terms of like quicksand.
Why is he gets this idea that
you're, can I get sucked in?
You're going to go too far.
You're going to get stuck in whatever
new world you've, you've ventured into.
And right now there isn't that anxiety
and exploration anymore. I mean,
quicksand in,
in Shakespeare's time was always off the
coasts of new continents that had to do
with the age of exploration
and then it became, you know,
desert quicksand and jungle
quicksand during colonial era.
And I just think the world is,
and then it became the moon. Yeah.
And then it became the moon.
And look at all the real estate
this beyond the don't come on.
I mean you got like our solar system,
you could have the quick sand of Jupiter.
Yes, absolutely. I think if we're going
to land humans on some black holes,
isn't black on black holes? A
kind of quick sand? Yeah. This,
this is my guarantee. If, if we're
about to land humans on some planet,
you know, beyond the moon,
these thoughts of quicksand
would re-emerge oh yeah,
this is Carlton cuse again.
And now we're going to see this
whole new chapter of Star Wars.
And clearly we just so
happens that the director,
JJ Abrams is working on a
whole new star wars movie. Yes.
And I think in the context
of some strange new world,
I think the audience would
totally buy quicksand there. Yeah,
that's what I'm, that's
what I'm hoping for. Yeah.
So I'll shoot JJ and email and just say
quicksand and just leave it at that.
See what happens.
[inaudible]
I have another leading indicator
of quicksand interest for you.
I have no idea what you're about
to say. None. So when I was a kid,
I played quicksand in the sandbox,
but sandboxes disappeared in the
1990s in New York City at least,
I don't know what the story
was in the rest of the country,
but this paper came out in the New
England Journal of Medicine and a warrant
that there might be some [inaudible]
derivative in sandbox sand.
And the number of sandboxes in New York
City went from something like 900 to 30
or 40 by the mid nineties and those
kids that you talked to in that class,
they had not likely sat in a sandbox
pouring water in the corner and worrying
it. But sandboxes are back the
new imaginative play movement and,
and playground redesign.
So it's just going to have all lots of
sand and lots of water and we want the
kids mixing the water in the sand.
So who knows? Maybe this is the,
this is the front edge of, uh,
of quicksand coming back because kids
are playing with water and sand and
sandboxes in New York City.
Oh, that's by the way,
on a more serious note,
I have actually one more leading
indicator of the return of quicksand.
I just saw it in the New York Times
actually on the front page in what
connection involving Syria, Syria were
there. They were referring to Syria.
A quicksand. Yeah.
And I think they've actually is come
up a little bit in terms of Afghanistan
too, but um, it kind of seems to be
back in [inaudible] yeah. In that,
in the political, soon
to, thank you. Sorry.
Thanks Aaron. Yeah, no problem. And, um,
I should say thanks to Dan [inaudible],
he's a writer and a calmness at slate
magazine where you can find his article
about quicksand.
And if you want to check out where the
radio lab live show is and when it is,
and how you can get there
and how you can get tickets,
you can do all of that at
radiolab.org/live thanks for listening.